I'm joined today by dr. Melanie joy who
is a harvard-educated psychologist and
author of the book why we love dogs eat
pigs and where cows she is also
president of beyond carnism where which
you can learn more about at carnism dot
org it's so great to talk to you I think
there's so many ways we could enter this
conversation and I'm going to do it in a
way that sort of will resonate with our
audience because if things I've talked
about the title of your book why we love
dogs and eat pigs I once decided that
upon spending some time around pigs and
learning about their intelligence and
really how they are similar to dogs in
many ways I decided I wasn't going to be
eating pigs anymore and I haven't eaten
pork in in many years and some people
when I tell them that it sort of makes
sense to them intuitively and others say
David that just it sounds so arbitrary
it doesn't really make any sense to me
and that arbitrariness is the first
thing I want to talk to you about
because as you've spoken about before
there are many different ways in which
human decisions about diet and eating
animals are sort of inherently arbitrary
and and I guess the question is are some
of those decisions more or less
arbitrary than others or is this just
inherent to human nature and decisions
about diets well first of all thanks for
having me on today I'm really looking
forward to talking about this issue with
you and an answer to your question it's
really important to recognize how our
decisions are made in the first place or
what the what forces are shaping our
attitudes and feelings and behaviors
when it comes to the decisions that we
make especially the decisions that have
a profound impact on others such as
whether to eat others or not or whether
to eat animals or not and my work
focuses on what I have referred to as
carnism this is the focus of my research
the invisible belief system or ideology
that conditions us to eat certain
animals so carnism is a it's a dominant
belief system so it's really woven
through the very structure of society to
shape norms laws the beliefs behavior
cetera and it becomes internalized
shaping the very way we think and feel
about eating animals and so really what
carnism teaches us to do is to classify
certain animals as edible and all the
rest is inedible and in meat-eating
cultures around the world people learn
to classify only a tiny handful of
animals as edible all the rest they
perceive as inedible and often even
offensive as most disgusting too soon
and so what does this tell us
some people will hear this and they'll
say well it sounds almost like like
you're you're referring to religious
doctrine people might think about halal
or kashrut guidelines that existed in
Islam and Judaism respectively but
you're really going well beyond that I
mean some of these guidelines may be for
some informed by religion but really
you're also talking about non-religious
sort of socio cultural norms right
exactly what I'm talking about is
ideology and more specifically an
irrational ideology it's important to
recognize that you know most of us share
the same core human values values such
as compassion and justice and what
systems such as carnism do that are
organized around violence you know meat
cannot be procured without violence and
egg and dairy production caused
extensive harm to animals
so most people would not willingly cause
this harm to animals especially or
animals suffering especially when the
suffering is so intensive and so
completely unnecessary and so what
carnism does is it distorts it uses a
set of Defense's that distort our
perceptions and numb our feelings so
that we act against our values without
fully realizing what we're doing and I
think there's something interesting
they're not not to interrupt but I think
there's something interesting and I want
to dig in a little bit to this idea of
most people like you said would not go
around willingly causing harm to others
and in this case where you're sort of
referring to the the animal industrial
complex for lack of a better term
might this not apply in many ways in
life I mean as a sort of just particular
example you could point out to people
who drive to work listen you're driving
to work is not good for the environment
do you realize that and you could also
make the case that none of those
individuals are willingly and
deliberately saying I want to harm the
environment and thus I am going to drive
to work so there must be something
beyond this right I mean is it is it
just this idea of rationalization or is
it the idea maybe of a greater good by
being at work I am doing more good maybe
than I am doing by polluting the
environment with my car and maybe
there's a sort of similar type of
internal irrational rationalized logic
that people might use for meat
consumption yeah I mean that's a great
point you know sometimes we do need to
maybe act against our values in order to
support the greater good but when it
comes to eating animals the vast
majority of us have completely
unexamined choices and when we look at
the facts we look at what the data tells
us eating animals causes not only the
the tremendous suffering and deaths of
77 billion land animals globally every
year it also causes harm to our bodies
as eating animal products isn't linked
with some of the leading causes of
disease believing diseases in the
developed world today
it causes extensive harm to the
environment there is no rational
argument today to my knowledge that one
could make that eating animals is in any
way in service of the greater good what
we try to do it beyond carnism is really
get people to you know we're not
advocating advocating telling people
what they should and shouldn't eat what
we're advocating is awareness we believe
that people need and deserve to know the
truth not simply about animal
agriculture and its consequences but out
about carnism and how it shapes our
perceptions so that we check our
critical thinking at the door when we
make some of the most frequent and
important choices that we do make in our
daily lives and with awareness people
can make their choices freely because
without awareness there is no free
choice I know that person
you're vegan and in much of what I've
seen you write and say about this issue
you talk both about sort of the
repercussions of eating meat but you
also talk about it as you and I have
been speaking about this sort of
arbitrary double standard that exists
with many animals that people choose to
eat or not to eat I I'd love to for you
to sort of break down a little bit how
important the double standard angle is
to you I mean if someone said it you
know I don't care about animals I
believe that objectively speaking this
isn't my view but if someone said I
believe animals are lesser than humans
and I don't care about animal suffering
I'm totally consistent I will eat any
animal is that someone that to you is at
least morally consistent and do you have
how much how much would you respect that
still in the context of your broader
views about environmental impact etc I'm
really less concerned with moral
consistency and more concerned with
people acting in alignment with their
natural empathy and practicing
compassion so that we can have the kind
of world that we most of us actually do
want to have so you know most people do
in fact care about animals we know for
example that humans and and some other
animals are actually hardwired to
empathize with others empathy is our
natural state and what systems such as
carnism do is they cause us to simply
disconnect from our natural empathy
toward those species we've learned to
classify as edible so what I think is
most important is not looking at simply
which animals we do eat which animals we
don't eat but really asking this
question how can I be more connected
with my authentic thoughts and feelings
so that I can make choices that are in
my own best interest and in the interest
the best interest of others there's been
pretty extensive writing about asserting
that were it not for eating meat much
longer ago in human history humans may
have died out right and to differing
degrees I'm sort of simplifying it but
this case has been made to differing
degrees in terms of meat as a portion of
a as one component
of the human diet what's your sense of
number one do you believe that
technology and sort of the modern world
now allow someone to not consume any
animal products and still be able to
live a normal life in society and if you
believe that at some point that was
necessary the consumption of animal
protein was necessary for the for the
survival of Homo sapiens when do you
think that that changed in other words
at what point did we come to dominate
agriculture and and our environment in
such a way that eating meat was no
longer necessary for survival
yeah I mean what I believe in terms of
you know whether eating animals is
healthy or not is significantly less
relevant in my opinion than what the
data show you know but the data I want
to make sure before you go I want to
make sure that we that I'm clear on my
question because I what my question was
do you believe that at some point eating
meat in the history of Homo sapiens was
indispensable and if so at what point
did we start to be able to get away from
me in a way that you believed it was no
longer necessary for our survival yeah I
mean I'm not a historian so I can't give
you hard facts on this what I do know is
that anthropologists say that our very
earliest ancestors were actually fruit
eaters like some other non-human
primates today are we evolved to eating
small amounts of meat because we did
have to and it's it's you know it's it's
clear that humans did at some point in
history eat other animals and they did
this in order to survive yeah but we
know that in the history of
vegetarianism ethical vegetarianism at
least is traced back to about 3500 years
3,500 years ago were the first
suggestions of the first I should say
people who chose to practice
vegetarianism for ethical and at that
time it was religious reasons we do have
a vast amount of literature today
research demonstrating that a
plant-based or vegan diet is not only a
healthy diet but can be beneficial in
the prevention and even treatment of
disease
so today there are some people in the
world who eat animals because they have
to they're geographically or
economically unable to make their food
choices freely but you know when a
behavior becomes a choice it takes on an
ethical dimension that it didn't have in
quite the same way before and for many
people in the world today they don't eat
animals because they have to they eat
animals because it's just the way things
are because they've been conditioned to
and not to recognize conditioned not to
recognize that there is an alternative
there is another way to be well
significant food for thought it is
fascinating and we will talk about of
course the book why we love dogs eat
pigs and wear cows and the ideas
presented in it in the future as well
we've been speaking with the book's
author dr. Melanie joy thanks so much
for talking to me about this thank you
so much for having me